هناك خبر عاجل فيما يبدو نقرا عن بلومبرج
هجوم بطائره مسيره مفخخه على الناقله
للنفط مملوكه لرجل اعمال اسرائيلي قباله
سواحل عمان
بتاكيد سنكون في متابعه تطورات وحيثيات
هذا الهجوم الذي نقلته مثل ما ذكرنا وكاله
بلومبرج هجوم اذا بطائره مسيره مفخخه على
الناقله للنفس مملوكه لرجل اعمال اسرائيلي
يضم الينا من مسقط مراسل الجزيره سمير
النمر سمير هل توفر التفاصيل اكثر حول هذا
الهجوم
لم تتوفر حتى الان اي معلومات ولم تصدر اي
مؤسسه عمانيه مختصه بشان هذا الهجوم وربما
نستمع او تصدر عده بيان التوضيحي اذا كان
ذلك يخص المياه الاقليميه العمانيه نحن
بالتاكيد نعرف ان سواحل عمان هي شريط طويل
جدا وممتد لالاف الكيلومترات وبالتالي لا
يمكن التشهد حتى هذه اللحظه همم اين يوجد
بالضبط او اين تم استهداف هذه السفينه هل
كان بالمياه الاقليميه الدوليه ام بالمياه
الاقليميه العمانيه
فقط الى هذا الخبر العاجل الذي نقلته
وكاله رويترز عن مسؤول امريكي عسكري بان
الاسطول الامريكيه الخامس على علم بوقوعه
حادث نتيجه جاريه في خليج عمان تفضل
نعم كنت اتحدث انها قد تم استهداف سفينه
مماثله لشركه اسرائيليه العامه الماضي
وكانت ذلك الاستعداد في المياه الدوليه
وليس بالمياه الاقليميه العمانيه
وبالتالي
سلطنه عمان ربما تكون على علم بهذا الحديث
نقرا
توضيحيه خلال ساعات القادمه اذا كان ذلك
الحادث يخص المياه الاقليميه العمانيه نحن
شهدنا خلال الاسابيع الماضيه والاشهر
الماضيه حراكا واسعا في تلك المنطقه همم
من قبل الاسطوره الخامس الامريكي وكذلك
القوات المسانده له من عده دول المتواجده
في هذه المنطقه من مكافحه ما سمي بالتهريب
بغير المشروع الاسلحه والمخدرات كانت
الاسطول الخامس الامريكي قد علينا القاء
القبض على عدد من السفن كانت متوجهه الى
مناطق غير معلومه او مناطق مجهوله وتلك
السفن هي سفن خشبيه همم كانت تتحرك في
المياه الدوليه وتحمل على متنها بعض
الاسلحه وكذلك المخدرات كان الحادث الذي
استهدف السفينه الاسرائيليه العام الماضي
قد ادى الى وفاه الى مقتل شخصين على متن
هذه السفينه عندما استهدف همم بطائره
مسيره ولم تعلن اي جهه حينها عن مسؤوليتها
عن هذا الحادث رغم اتهامات بعض الدول
الغربيه والتي تشير دائما بطريقه مباشره
او غير مباشره الى وقوع في جماعه او
ميليشيات تابعه لايران
اذن سمير يعني ربما المعلومات ما زالت
شحيحه لكن يعني معرفه المكان الذي تم
استهداف فيها هذه الناقله ايضا يوضح لنا
من اين اتت هذه المسيره ان كانت من الشمال
عمان او من جنوبها نعم نعلم يعني امتداد
وقرب عمان على هذا الشريط الطويل الساحلي
شمالا الى ايران وجنوبا الى اليمن فان
كانت من معلومات متوفره حول مكان استهداف
هذه الناقله
لا محمد حتى هذه اللحظات لم تتضح بعد مكان
استهداف هذه مكان هذا الاستهداف هل تم في
المياه الدوليه وهي مياه طويله وتحدثنا
انها تمتد لالاف الكيلومترات من مضيقي
هرمز شمالا وحتى المندب جنوبا
واما اذا كان في المياه الاقليميه
العمانيه لم تعلن حتى الان تفاصيل هذا
الحادث ربما خلال الساعات القادمه نشهد
توضيحا لمكان الاستهداف في السفينه
الماضيه كان الاستهداف في المياه الدوليه
بالطبع مقابل او امام السواحل العمانيه
ولكنه ليس في المياه الاقليميه العمانيه
وكانت السلطات العمانيه في حينها قد اصدرت
بيانا اوضحت فيه ذلك بالتفصيل وانها قامت
ايضا البحريه العمانيه بمساعده هذه
فينا ونقل اا المصابين للعلاج بمساعده
الاسطول الخامس الامريكي المتواجد في هذه
المنطقه الى جانب عدد من الدول اا وذلك
لتامين خطوط النقل النفط نحن نعرف ان هذه
المنطقه هي المنطقه حساسه جدا لانها همم
تتوجه فيها يوميا مئات الناقلات التجاريه
والنفسيه التي تتوجه الى مياه الخليج في
الشمال وباتجاه جنوبا باتجاه الهند
والطريق الى الصين والدول الاوروبيه مرورا
بباب المندب هذه المنطقه كانت تشهد على
المرار نوع من الهجمات وربما كثير منها
كانت همم لا تعلن اي جهاز مسؤوليتها
المباشره عن عن هذه الاستهلاك لانه
استهداف للاقتصاد العالمي وسيؤثر بشكل
كبير جدا همم
تمر منه يوميا كما ذكرته مئات الناقلات
النفسيه نحن ننتظر خلال الساعات القادمه
ربما يتوضح اكثر وينكشف المشهد بشكل كبير
من هي الجهه واين تم استهداف هذه السفينه
هل في المياه الاقليميه
العمانيه او المياه الدوليه والتي لا تتبع
جهام معينه او دوله معينه وحمايتها يتحكم
على الاطار العالمي واثاره الدولي ونحن
نشهد حراك العسكريه في هذه المنطقه
لتامينها من ايتها هجمات